lab muffin is 10 years old the concept
not me this isn't some sort of weird
leap year thing in case you didn't know
lab muffin started as a blog before it
expanded into this youtube channel in
2017. the 10-year anniversary was in
december my very first blog post was on
the 5th of december 2011
and my first real blog post was on the
9th of december and that was called
chemical versus natural which was
talking about all the myths around
natural beauty products which was like
the earlier fetus version of clean
beauty
now lab muffin is my full-time job and i
never thought it would ever come to this
it is pretty much my dream job so thank
you so much to everyone who's been
supporting me and making this possible i
asked everyone to send in questions they
had about lab muffins so this video is
going to be like a big overview of who i
am how i got here what i've learned on
the way behind the scenes of lab muffin
sort of like how the sausages are made
in case you haven't already subscribed
do that like the video and click the
notification bell so you get notified
when there are new videos biggest
changes within the science skin care
community everyone knows a lot more of
the basics now which i like to think is
partly because of me
and because of that i think people are a
lot more interested in knowing the
details and really understanding
everything at a much deeper level the
really nice thing about this is that i
can talk about much deeper topics that i
never thought i'd be able to tackle
things like the math behind calculating
whether or not you need indoor sunscreen
the mechanism behind how different
sunscreens work which is really
incredible 30 000 people watch me talk
about electronic transitions between
quantized energy levels and that to me
is absolutely mind-blowing on the bad
side i think marketing myths have gotten
a lot more complex and sophisticated and
so they've become a lot harder to debunk
and if you've heard of brandolini's law
which is also known as the bs asymmetry
principle you need to put in a lot more
effort to debunk stuff than to put out
garbage also maybe we care a little bit
too much about the details these days
maybe we're getting bogged down in
things that don't really make a huge
difference at the end of the day a lot
of the time with skincare there just
isn't a clear-cut answer and the best
thing to do is really just look at
reviews from people you trust and just
try things for yourself rather than
trying to logic it out from a scientific
perspective over the ten years name the
top three most infuriating myths you've
heard i think number one has to be
sunscreen is causing more skin cancer
than the sun because this is just
straight up dangerous misinformation i
live in australia and i know a lot of
people who have skin cancer now and
maybe they could have prevented that
with sunscreen there's also the whole
beauty companies are just trying to kill
you because they want to make more money
thing that a lot of clean beauty tends
to promote this is one of the reasons i
started my blog it is basically just a
big pharma conspiracy theory but for
beauty my mom falls for this one a lot
and that's another reason i started my
blog because i was going down all these
rabbit holes trying to convince my mum
not to just throw out all of her shampoo
fear is a really powerful emotion it's
really fundamental to the way that we
humans evolved and i think it's just so
scummy when beauty brands try to exploit
this and manipulate you and make you
feel really scared to try to get a
profit there's also the whole idea that
there's no science in cosmetics and
there is for example skin care is pretty
much just applied medicinal chemistry
there are lots of reasons why the
evidence doesn't look as rigorous as
maybe it is or maybe it should be and a
lot of that is just because of the
legalities around how skin care is
regulated this is the whole drug versus
cosmetic thing that i've talked about
before there just isn't a lot of
incentive for companies to actually run
rigorous studies even if that particular
ingredient is really well supported by
the evidence so far and so this leads to
a lot of lazy debunkings things like
saying collagen cannot possibly work
because they just didn't bother doing a
literature search that whole zinc study
where they looked at sunscreens but they
only looked as sunscreen technologies
that are 30 years old i think a lot of
this comes from this idea that cosmetic
science is female and frivolous and so
there can't possibly be any science in
it if you look at areas with lots of
pseudoscience but it's mostly male
dominated things like
gym junkie bro science then cars and
tech
you see that people are a lot more
careful when they debunk things there
they take it a lot more seriously and
they do a lot more background research
they don't just go in there and assume
they know everything and yeah i think it
does come down to the idea that
cosmetics is a lot more frivolous and
fluffy and there's just zero science
there even though we have these
multinational companies that hire lots
and lots of scientists in cosmetics
negativity and hate most people are
really supportive skincare creators are
generally really nice i do tend to get
more hate when i'm doing myth-busting
stuff because sometimes i am talking
about people's deep-seated beliefs it
can affect people's businesses so
it's understandable that people often
have a pretty bad initial reaction
sometimes it's even just people who are
big fans of the brand maybe they've
tried a whole bunch of face creams and
this is the one face cream that works
but the brand happens to have a whole
bunch of dodgy marketing sometimes it's
from people who did sponsored posts for
a product i criticized there was the
propaganda video that was when i got
cited as a propaganda source twice in a
peer-reviewed article and he sometimes
comments on my blog as well it's very
strange with misrepresentation it
happens a lot and i think it's pretty
unavoidable a lot of the time my stances
are pretty complex and it's pretty easy
to misrepresent them if they get
summarized i'm pretty sure i've
misrepresented my own beliefs i've had a
science brand try to debunk my fatty
acids and oils video and they just used
a whole bunch of points that i addressed
in the video in terms of dealing with it
it depends on the exact situation if
it's a common misconception then i try
to address it publicly or maybe if they
have a really large reach sometimes i
reach out to them privately and try to
sort it out that way and sometimes i
think it's best to just ignore it and
like go out and touch some grass do
people in real life raise an eyebrow
when they find out i'm a skincare
content creator yes i think it's kind of
50 50. some scientists especially those
in academia think it's really silly
because of that whole there's no science
and cosmetics thing but a lot of people
are really supportive including a lot of
my male scientist colleagues who think
it's pretty cool my boss at my tutoring
college who never uses social media has
been just so supportive he's always
helping me out with any physics
questions i have he lent me the thermal
camera that i've been using how do you
decide which companies to work with with
my sponsorship selection process the
ultimate test is
will people who can't buy this product
at all maybe they live in antarctica
will they get something useful or
interesting out of this piece of content
so obviously it has to be based on
interesting science it has to be
scientifically accurate and i have to
actually like the product most of the
brands i work with are because i've used
their products before and i tried it and
liked it and posted about it and that's
why they reached out to me for a
sponsorship if i haven't tried the
product before and i think i might like
it they have to send it to me and i try
it before i sign any contracts there are
sponsorships that have fallen through
because even though the product was
perfectly good i just didn't like it and
that's because i think even if the
science is interesting and i explain it
at the end of the day people are going
to ask me do i recommend this product
did i like the product and i want to be
able to say yes there's been one
exception where i didn't like the
product but they wanted me to make
purely educational content and that was
pantene and that's just because i'm
allergic to the preservatives they use
so i can't actually use their product
have you ever faced a situation where
sponsors weren't happy with my
scientific evaluation of the product
it's actually incredibly rare that i get
any pushback on the facts that i talk
about in a sponsored piece of content
part of it is that i'm really choosy
with my sponsorships and the brief is
actually in the contract so you can see
it before you sign it generally this is
like in appendix a and if there's
anything in that that i'm not
comfortable with if it's not
scientifically accurate if there's not
enough evidence for it then i'll usually
ask for it to be taken out of the
contract if it's like a small thing if
there's way too much in there that i
disagree with then i just don't sign the
contract 99 of the time the edits that i
have to make aren't ashley factual most
of the time i get no edits so of the
edits i've recently had to make i've
pronounced something wrong i got the
price wrong sometimes they want a
particular shot in the content so maybe
i didn't show applying the product or
maybe the label got a bit blurry a
couple of times they've changed the
packaging since i shot it and they
wanted me to reshoot that content
sometimes they want me to reword things
for legal reasons or include disclaimers
for example with sunscreens in australia
you have to have a particular disclaimer
i think once they didn't want me to
mention a competitor because they didn't
want to risk getting sued there is one
piece of feedback that i absolutely hate
that i've gotten a lot less pushback on
and that's changing the language of the
disclosure a few years back i used to
always get feedback to change sponsored
to partner or collab but these days it's
gotten a lot less it's also a lot easier
to argue against now because australia
now has clear legal guidelines and i can
point at them and they know they can't
negotiate with that brand's getting
upset blacklisting me giving me legal
threats so after i criticize a brand
usually it's 50 50 whether they respond
well or badly some brands are really
nice about it they thank me they tell me
they want to do better and
i'm sure sometimes it is just lip
service and we should hold brands
accountable for making these changes but
it definitely looks better from a pr
perspective it's much better than the
alternative where they respond really
badly i've been blacklisted a few times
from different brands and different pr
companies one brand i criticized
contacted my management and reminded
them about their sponsorships with their
other creators which i thought was
a bit much how do you go about
researching a new topic this really
depends on the topic and my process as
always is a little bit chaotic so let's
say i'm trying to talk about a new
publication my first step is to make
sure i really understand the background
these days it's a bit easier because
i've done so much background reading for
everything else already i would read
through the paper really closely
sentence by sentence and look up
anything i don't understand usually this
is by looking through textbooks you do
have to be a bit careful with textbooks
because they're sometimes a bit of
inaccurate stuff they're not really peer
reviewed so you do have to check against
other sources check against your
existing knowledge and check what
experts think usually in this process
there are a lot of detours it is rarely
straightforward where i can just read a
paper from start to end it can take
about six hours to read through say a
three-page paper i think a key part for
working out the correct direction for a
topic is just knowing who the right
experts are for example whether mineral
sunscreens absorb or reflect uv if
you're a dermatologist it doesn't
actually matter to you which one it is
as long as the sunscreen works a
physical chemist would have to know
because firstly they would use different
machines to measure the uv protection if
it reflected or if it absorbed and
secondly it has to do with the
microscopic structure of that chemical
if you're trying to work out if
sunscreens cause or prevent skin cancer
then dermatologists toxicologists and
regulators would be really relevant but
a physical chemist or a choral scientist
wouldn't be relevant
so i think it's really important to work
out whose opinion to give more weight to
which video took the longest there are
videos that have been sitting on the
back burner for months because they just
won't quite come together and i don't
want to say the topics because i don't
want to give people false hope a lot of
these topics are things that people have
suggested to me so don't feel like every
time you give me a recommendation for a
topic it just goes into the ether i
write them all down and someday i hope
to cover them all but
yeah i am one person and unfortunately
things take a lot of time sometimes it
isn't even the volume of research that's
tricky sometimes is collaboration
basically every time i do a
collaboration i have to start a whole
new process and it takes ages trying to
work out how to edit people in without
misrepresenting them and still making
the video flow together really nicely
out of the videos i've done so far
probably the longest ones have been the
clean beauty one which had dr fred
editing his stuff down was pretty tricky
it took me months to work out how to
make it sit together but i'm really
really happy with final product and he
was happy with it too another video that
took ages was the alcohol video which
had kind of stephen who i'm sure a lot
of you know that one took ages because
we were trying to research together
while coordinating through a google
document between canada and australia so
that was just sort of like a logistical
thing and also we were sitting on it for
ages trying to work out what the best
way to tell that story was as well one
of the videos where the research
actually took a really long time was the
coral reef video on reef safe sunscreens
and that was because when i made it
there wasn't that much published about
it so
i had a really difficult time trying to
work out what the general scientific
consensus was so i had to dig through
mailing list archives through emails
between choral scientists these days
it's a lot easier because there have
been new review studies that have been
published which confirm what i worked
out but yeah having to work out what was
happening in a topic that isn't really
entirely my field was really tricky the
skincare oils and free fatty acids video
also took ages because i had to skim
through hundreds of papers no one had
really researched this topic directly so
i had to put it all together through
studies that accidentally gave me the
info i needed the after crowning
propaganda video was also quite
difficult because i was in a weird
headspace at the time i had a lot going
on in my life and you can sort of tell i
got kind of ambitious about it i was
trying to make that whole taylor swift
meme sequence and yeah whenever i get a
really good idea and i really want to
make it work
i generally don't have the skills to
make it work so that one required a lot
of outside help so i got a lot of
questions about my educational
background in high school i was actually
more interested in arts i took drama
history full unit english for unit maths
and chemistry i was good at physics and
bio but i wasn't as interested in them
and i just really liked chemistry i
really liked how chemistry explained a
lot of things that i saw in everyday
life because everything could just be
linked back to the fundamentals of how
molecules interact with each other
things like why you get condensation on
the outside of cold drink why raindrops
merge on a window why you get bubbles
from detergent why if you have dry
pencil lead it makes your hand dirty
whereas like if you have dry pen ink it
doesn't how like different painkillers
worked so i went to a really academic
high school and we had these lunchtime
chemistry classes and my friend went to
it so i tagged along it was sort of like
more of a social event for me here's
something that i think might be a bit
unexpected i don't think i started off
naturally good at chemistry but because
i went to all these extra lunchtime
classes mostly to hang out with my
friends i got a lot of practice and then
i got good at chemistry i think that's
actually why i'm good at teaching
chemistry because i have an insight into
what it's like to suck at chemistry in
australia there's a system where you get
a mark at the end of high school and
then different uni courses have
different cutoff marks and so there's
this stupid idea of not wasting your
marks so a lot of people in my high
school get pressured into doing medicine
or law and so i picked combined law at
sydney uni at the time it had the
highest entry mark so i wasted less of
my marks and a lot of my friends were
doing law it seemed like a respectable
job and it's the top law school in the
country i combined law with science for
two reasons the main one was when i was
17 science sounded like something that
would be a bit more of a useful degree
than arts also because i went to those
lunchtime classes i ended up being top
20 in the state for chemistry olympiad
and that meant you could actually skip
first year chemistry so basically my
approach was i picked subjects i was
somewhat interested in and potentially
had a career after it and if i could get
higher marks without as much effort then
even better so my science courses were
chemistry psychology maths pharmacology
and physiology so the idea was i could
become a patient attorney or potentially
go into drug design i was really
fascinated by how different substances
could have like really different effects
on your body so
different things could get you to stop
sneezing or stop your headache or
hallucinate or drop dead um my parents
are nurses so when i was a kid i got a
lot of random stuff given to me when i
was sick so after the first three years
of undergrad i paused law for a year to
do honours in chemistry i ended up
dropping law because even though i love
studying law it turns out i hated
working in a law firm the project i was
working on was where my law firm was
representing a tobacco company
and i never really considered myself a
super moral person i assumed if i got
paid enough then i would be comfortable
giving fair representation to any party
because that's what all lawyers should
be doing
but it just slowly ate away at me that i
was working so hard and the harder i was
working the more i was helping what to
me seem like the bad guys win there's no
judgment for me for people who do this
kind of work i have a lot of friends in
law and i think detachment is a really
useful skill but it just isn't the way
i'm built so because of that experience
i'm a big believer in trying out lots of
different things if you think you might
be interested in something then just try
it out because you don't really know
what it's like unless you immerse
yourself in that experience if you can't
get practical hands-on experience then
try to talk to people who work in the
fields that you might want to go into so
hopefully you get a better feel for what
actually interests you and what you
enjoy doing and whether or not that
field matches that so i discovered that
a lot of people become patient attorneys
after getting a phd so doing a phd
seemed like a good way to keep both of
those patient attorneys drug design
parts open my psg was a continuation of
my honest project which was really
interesting it was on medicinal and
super molecular chemistry i also made a
lot of friends with my cohort and a lot
of us decided to continue our phd so
that was a really nice group of people
to be around there was also the fact
that the admin to change unis let alone
countries was just a lot i'm really bad
with dealing with admin and staying at
sydney uni was just like filling in two
pages so that's the not very inspiring
story of how i ended up doing a phd what
made you decide to go the cycom route
and not stay in academia i've always
really enjoyed teaching so during my phd
i did a bit of lab teaching and i also
taught tutorials to undergrads i also
did a lot of tutoring before this so my
first tutoring job was at 14 and when i
was a kid i actually remember inventing
multiple choice tests for my friends to
do so that they could join a club yeah i
was just a really annoying child so
there's just not that much teaching in
academia a lot of academia just revolves
around research but a lot of cycom is
pretty much like teaching so that's
another reason why i started lab muffin
at the time people told you that if you
wanted to go into cycom you should start
a blog as like a portfolio and it could
really show that you were truly
interested in cycom so i think the main
thing that got me out of thinking of
academia as a long-term job was that
there was a fire in my lab in 2012 it
was the final year of my phd and i was
in the lab where the fire was and i
pretty much just saw my life flash
before my eyes our labs were organized
so that all the organic chemists were on
one level and organic chemistry involves
a lot of really flammable solvents so
you can basically imagine it was just a
lab where on top of every lab desk there
was just a bunch of petrol in my mind in
that moment i thought the whole building
would just go up in flames i could just
see
a wall of flames just like exploding
towards me
it didn't the fire was actually confined
to a really small area but
that incident affected me a lot i had
ptsd for about six months i had
nightmares every single night when i
went back near that building i got this
really uncomfortable like skin crawling
feeling and it made finishing my phd
really difficult i didn't publish as
many papers as i probably could have i
took a bit longer than i should have as
well that incident really highlighted
that i love chemistry but not enough to
die because someone else screwed up so
after i graduated i didn't really know
what to do i lived in switzerland for
half a year with my partner at the time
i got really depressed i worked on my
blog i became a moderator on skincare
addiction on reddit i started teaching
at matrix education to earn some money
on the side this is a tutoring college
that does usually classes of 15. they
hire a lot of phd students and they paid
really well and about six months later
they offered me a full-time position as
a chemistry coordinator so i was in
charge of hiring teachers teaching and
writing the teaching materials so i was
writing the textbooks and inventing
experiments and so i sort of just fell
into that role and i found that i
absolutely loved it i stayed there until
i went full time with lab muffin and i
still teach there a few hours a week
where did the name lab muffin come from
this story is just not that exciting um
so i knew i wanted to do a blog i
couldn't think of a name
and so i couldn't really start doing my
blog for about four weeks and i knew i
just had to start so i settled on lab
muffin i was sitting in a lab at the
time when i set up my first blogspot
account muffin was the nickname from my
partner at the time i told myself i
could just start and then change the
name later and i just never thought up a
better name and i never got around to
changing it so the good thing about the
phrase lab muffin is that it is like a
brand new sentence which means it's very
search engine friendly so back in 2012
if you typed in lab muffin into google i
would be the first result so if you're
trying to pick an online handle and you
want to be very easily searchable i
would definitely recommend something
relatively unique and easy to spell lab
muffin worked really well for that if
you have a really distinctive name then
i would just go with your name
but that wasn't an option for me because
there were literally 27 other michelle
wongs back when i tried to sign up to
hotmail in 1997. how did your phd slash
degree help you with your career and
what did you have to learn yourself so
my phd project was on cyclic peptides i
was making them and then exploring their
uses as drugs and supreme molecular
scaffolds so that combined with my
undergrad subjects gave me a really good
background understanding of things like
chemistry pharmacology physiology and
medicinal chemistry so from that i was
really used to looking at things like
ligands and biochemical pathways
but i never really looked at anything
like retinoids specifically so i think
more importantly i developed a lot of
other skills from my phd training and
from my previous job during a typical
phd you have to defend your ideas
against people who are
kind of trying to make you break it's a
bit toxic some people cry but you kind
of get used to having to really critique
your own ideas so that you can work out
all the flaws before you go up on stage
and have to publicly defend yourself
writing the textbooks was also really
good training because the audience was
both chemistry phds and phd students who
are teaching it and the high school
students so you had to make it work for
a lot of different people when did you
realize you could go full time as a
science communicator so in 2017 i added
banner ads to my blog and that's when
financially i started making more money
than i was spending on lab muffin and
that's when it started looking like it
could potentially be a part-time job i
was starting to get over a thousand
dollars a month without a ton of effort
and i really wish i discovered this a
lot earlier on and not six years in so
yeah i guess my advice would be if
there's a hobby that you love doing see
if you can make money out of it earlier
on in late 2017 i started my youtube
channel and that's when i started to get
a lot more sponsorship opportunities and
the workload started to really ramp up
by late 2018 i was working on lab muffin
on the train to and from work and every
weekend i pretty much had no life i
worked like 70 to 80 hours a week i was
basically in lockdown before lockdown
was a thing my accountant didn't
actually believe how many hours i worked
until i showed her my records every
sunday monday which was my weekend i'd
literally get out of bed stumble across
the room to my chair and then work
straight from 9am to 1am i went out of
my room for meals and for bathroom
breaks and that was it i do not
recommend this at all i recommend trying
to figure out a way to avoid this as
early as you can by the middle of 2019 i
was making enough money from content
creation that it could be a full-time
job and i was just about to burn out
from working every single waking moment
i was constantly shallow breathing i had
a racing heart my memory was getting
really bad and i was starting to get
these like weird feelings in my legs
like i was getting little clots
so i resigned um i'm still not really
good at that whole work-life balance
thing but it has gotten a lot better so
starting out and staying motivated i
think one of the things that really kept
me going was having a nice community
around me there were a lot of other
bloggers back in the day and we all used
to comment on each other's blogs not in
like an organized way but just being
really supportive there wasn't like an
algorithm back then so we weren't really
like boosting each other's posts like
you might on instagram it was just like
a really nice supportive environment
there was also this nail polish tag that
was going around back in the day and
every week we would have artsy wednesday
where we would have a different nail art
theme and i think these sorts of
techniques still work in the age of
social media just having lots of support
and working on nice collaborative
projects i also just felt like the
content i was making just needed to be
made no one else was making this sort of
thing back in the day so things like
scientific deep dives and myth busting
in a way that's accurate but also people
could really understand
but on the other hand there was a lot of
pseudoscience going around and so i kind
of felt like
this sort of i guess duty to keep making
my sort of content how do you get
started as a cosmetic chemist is a phd
necessary was it difficult so cosmetic
chemist is a qualification and i did my
diploma for this with the institute of
personal care science it's a very
popular program that's widely recognized
in the industry you definitely don't
need a phd to do it i think you need the
equivalent of a high school certificate
it is definitely harder to understand
what's going on without some sort of
science background and you probably
won't get as deep an understanding out
of it but it is definitely doable and if
you're interested i would highly
recommend it what makes you happiest
about doing youtube and lab muffin i'm
just a bit of a massive nerd i love
understanding stuff at a really deep
level and then explaining it to other
people i also really love the whole
creative process of creating content
whether it's presentations or diagrams
or textbooks or videos what would you
say is the most important part in
translating science to the wider
population i think accuracy is obviously
really important but also empathy just
understanding what level of complexity
people can handle what analogies would
work best for explaining something and
what feels satisfying because what tends
to work really well for myth busting is
giving people a narrative that makes
more sense than the myth you have to
help replace that with the truth what
did you study to improve the delivery of
your blog posts and videos i think this
is one of those things where the best
thing you can do is just practice a lot
just make content get feedback and then
incorporate that into your next piece of
content i think teaching is also really
helpful because it's like delivering
content and getting that real-time
feedback and this doesn't have to be
formal teaching you could just try
explaining the topic you're trying to
make content about to your friends or to
your family what are the pros and cons
of writing versus videos so i started
making videos because i felt a bit
constrained by blog posts some things
are just really hard to show you really
sort of need an animation or something
moving videos do take a lot longer
though minus the research a blog post
would take about three hours whereas a
video would take 20 hours difficulties
with using social media i think the most
annoying thing about social media is
that you have to make the algorithm
happy to get any sort of reach your
posts don't get shown to your audience
unless you tick off a whole bunch of
boxes which change all the time and that
might not be the best thing for that
particular piece of content maybe you
need to have a static post with lots of
words but the algorithm wants you to
make videos social media is also pretty
intrusive it's designed to make you want
to check it all the time and so if
that's part of your work then your
work-life balance is a bit messed up
it's particularly bad because i'm in
australia and so the peak times for
social media are weird hours for me
things like 2am on the other hand i do
kind of like that the algorithm changes
all the time because i like a challenge
i have a short attention span and so i
like making lots of diverse content what
are the best and worst parts of your job
i think the best thing is that i'm quite
a creative person and so my job is just
my entire creative outlet if you get
bored of doing the same thing all the
time then this job is fantastic the
worst thing is that the harder you work
the more you're rewarded and so that is
really bad for work-life balance also
because it's like an internet job it
constantly feels really insecure like
the algorithm might screw me over at any
moment and i would no longer have a job
i don't think this is unique to making
content or being a science communicator
i've heard similar things from a lot of
people who own their own businesses and
there are also content creators and
science communicators who are doing it
as part of a full-time salary job and so
they won't have the same issues one of
the things that really helped me with
time management is an app called toggle
i use it to record how much time it took
me to do particular things and so that
way i can better estimate how long it's
going to take me to do similar things in
the future it's really good for not over
committing yourself microphones software
camera lights i'm going to take you on a
little behind the scenes tour alright so
here is my filming setup this is my blue
microphone it's a yeti x which was
gifted
that is running into a laptop on my left
in front of me i have my old s8 which is
what i film on it is currently attached
to an ice pack because it's really hot
today and it kept overheating that's
connected to a teleprompter you can see
my old phone there as well reflecting
into that this teleprompter has been
really good i've only had it for a few
months and it's made my video making so
much quicker because of the teleprompter
means i can't actually touch my phone so
my phone is attached to my tablet so
this is connected with samsung flow and
so i can control the phone through this
tablet this is my lighting situation i
have a softbox and behind that i have i
don't know this like led array that led
array lights up my background and that's
also why sometimes my face looks lighter
than the rest of my body because
the light from that gets blocked off by
the softbox i'm sure you've seen my
background a million times and the
reason there's so much clutter around
here is actually i tried to have a
really nice empty studio but it turns
out having lots of stuff around is
really good for audio quality i don't
know if anyone's noticed this but i have
a little box here that's just full of
spatulas what platform is most lucrative
for you is blogging truly dead so this
might be a bit surprising but my ad
income is actually much better from my
blog than youtube even though i spend so
much more time on youtube there are lots
of blogs that are doing way better than
me as well especially food blogs i do
think it's a little bit harder to get
established as a blog these days because
google does rank you higher if you've
got an older website so if you are
planning to start a blog then i would
recommend doing it alongside social
media because discoverability is a lot
better on social media in terms of
sponsorships i get the most money from
instagram because i can produce a lot
more sponsored instagram content than i
can with youtube videos youtube videos
take so long to make is there a point
where skincare can become obsessive or
unhealthy definitely i think a lot of
people overthink skin care it's easy to
just take the scientific evidence too
seriously in skin care a lot of it is
just not that clear-cut the evidence is
really weak and i feel like a lot of
myths come from just overthinking that
evidence whenever you see a strict rule
for anything usually that's pretty
suspect because there aren't that many
studies out there on non-medical skin
care in science you generally need lots
of replicated studies to be sure about
things and that just doesn't really
exist in skincare i think a lot of the
time getting obsessive about skin care
is more of a symptom and it's not skin
care causing the obsession a lot of
people who come to skin care come there
because of self-esteem issues and skin
care just becomes an outlet what have
you believed in the past that turned out
to be myths pretty much every older myth
i've debunked i've probably believed for
example sunscreen scattering and
reflecting uv this doesn't happen as
much anymore because over the years i've
become a lot more cynical and so now if
there's any new claims i just start off
not believing it by default so i got a
lot of questions about my future plans
and i do have some ideas for things that
i really want to branch into but i don't
want to say too much because
again i don't like mentioning things
that i'm working on because i have so
many ideas that i just don't take
through to completion i do think i
managed to do a decent amount of stuff
but there is only one of me and so it's
really hard to get everything i want
done i do not have plans for a skincare
line maybe in the future i could see
myself collaborating with someone but
i don't think i can start my own line
because i would just end up spending all
day doing stuff that i don't like in
other words just doing admin hopefully
this video was interesting and gave you
an insight into how lab muffin works it
would be really sad if i released this
video and then quit in a month but
hopefully that doesn't happen hopefully
there will be a 15-year video as well
thank you so much to everyone who's been
supporting me and allowing this to
become my full-time job especially if
you've been following since back with
the blog days back when i used to do
nail art i think it's really cool that
we've built up this nerd community over
the last decade and hopefully it keeps
going